yeah hello and welcome to this video
which which reaches some another game
from the 45 45 diggin ditches and i'm
just going to pronounce those names
correctly that skillet i can do it and
draws 0 are the players and we have a
Sicilian defense wear white goes for c3
the elephant variation yeah c3 is one of
the better sight lines against Sicilian
there are some men are not all that
great like fo on let's say em please the
Groth free attack not a new trend of
those but c3 is a completely respectable
system that you can play up to a pretty
high level if you enjoy the positions
I'm certainly recommended wife's idea of
course is to play d4 for full center
which is also why the most popular
responsive involves direct attack
against the pond so that easy d 4 is not
so possible like this for example please
white has to react first one in this
game defilers played after which right
more or less has to take ya black screen
get to the center quite quickly but
that's not a huge issue if 93 is not
possible whenever the c3 rc6 move has
been played putting the Queen on d4 here
d5 gets a bit more interesting it's also
important to note that black in many
cases after d 4 which is the main move
does not want to take on d4 quickly as
this gives why the nitrous III in the
game here why place the move Knight f3
this urn is perfectly reasonable as long
as you continue with a quick deform my
about the knight c6 the white player did
not go for d 4 which is well the only
move is strong maybe something like
night a three years
so quite ok but d4 is the most logical
move put the stone in the center yeah
yeah we can get this rather common iqp
position where white has an isolated
creamed corn this could happen for
example after something like Knight f6
I'm let's say but should be 36 we should
be 3 and something like that is a normal
way how this opening I can turn white
has an isolated screen porn that I could
be but very good active development
Saudi for is the normal situation of
course they have some other
opportunities black can go here for
example yeah choose something else all
together with with g6 base set up sorry
for the didn't wanted me to paint that
let me I'm pain place what's going on
here I'm sorry for that what the heck ok
now it's also gone yeah sorry I mean
default what why should play but Bishop
b5 was played instead and yeah this is
not such a great move this Bishop does
never really want to take on c6 as it
would give up the bishop pair and we can
the light squares considerably and if
you don't want to take on g6 it's quite
and clear what this Bishop is actually
doing what the purpose of the move is ok
you pin but a black is not irritated by
thanks so much in fact he has a counter
pin with Bishop g4 after which wide
already felt compelled to return with
the bishop on e2 and this definitely
show us that we should be five now
followed with further but Bishop e2
wasn't such a great idea I mean there
should be two was not necessary white
also could have played downplayed move
castles or so but definitely something
even something like that you probably
would rather yeah I'd like to have black
what structures is damaged quite a bit
yeah so we should be tours played
basically admitting that this opening
didn't work out so well 96 in our casual
displayed here I would again recommend
to play deform we can also insert h3 and
then before but it's just about you need
to put some corn in the center this is a
theoretical variation a full move down
which is not grained of course but still
I'd rather have this for example on a
line like this should still be roughly
equal white pieces are active and it's
not so easy for black to do something
direct against the part something like a
cactus can also be tried sure p.m. and
so on the IQ p of course is aesthetic
weakness but as long as you have many
minor pieces on the board and active
it's not just a big deal I would
definitely prefer to have this temple
down position with deform makeup catch
of the game where white went castles and
black made the right decisions would be
five and now black is on that the four
squares a million times and it's not
easy for wide to trade you for now
anymore if he does efore is just better
for black well so what did he do after
you file he played to move age three
checking the bishop which now traded
itself that make sense just gain time
this and e4 that's the time Dana rookie
one utilizing the pin on the usual so
like has gained lots of space and yeah
sometimes we should have three I'm here
it was his turn to move and I think he
missed an opportunity here to get an
even bigger advantage compared to what
he got in the game so here I think long
capsules is a good move just cancel away
from the e-file and with the with a long
castling there's already big pressure so
[Music]
here it will be difficult for white to
get this freedom in the first place here
black has a nice choice he can play
there should be seven but it also may be
56 see and hear an idea like we need
five on Bishop see 726 can lead to a
dangerous attack on white skin White's
development is not great he's got three
pieces still at home I think we all
casuals was was a better choice compared
to the game we should be seven was not
bad but I think long castles was a bit
more powerful here white after Bishop e2
I think threatens to play d3 just to get
the bishop out finally and black did not
react to that idea strangely enough he
could have played Ruth the eighth after
which there is pressure on the dupont
and the move III is not possible so
easily I think I'd prefer that over
castles after capsules now White has an
opportunity to equalize the game again
by playing pawn to d3 surprisingly he
did not play this move after these three
I think Y can be quite happy
he's behind in development but it's
tough to see anything else now I would
like them to take and if you look at
this kind of position here why this
definitely okay you can even argue that
while you might have to slightly better
chances long-term with the two bishops
oh I would like some mobilization is
pretty good so why does not yeah
substantially better but definitely okay
in the game he did not play that it
played b3 and this is a really quite a
big mistake d3 was absolutely mandatory
get the bishop into the game now off to
be 3d might have we should be two or
that's very slow and you still have to
worry about the pawn which is on behalf
open file and constantly under pressure
yeah rupee eight was played again look
the eight was a good alternative but who
create is also fine we should be too
yeah again probably might should play d3
in though it is a creative less
effective then it was before because b3
is a bit of a non-move doesn't really
help at all still better than the game
after Bishop e2 group the eight now
there is enough pressure here on the D
file so that again the deep one cannot
move and black is yeah just enjoying
himself quite a bit hear think and we
have to clean to see two and now Queen
g5 that's a good move another good move
what we should be six and ten in Queen
to e5 this is a given us even stronger
by the engine but 25 is already very
good it has a very nice point that it
looked
coupon so further development I widest
difficult to play as t2 has to be taken
care and there are clear taking chances
based on the bishop move and maybe
create a form or just bring stuff like
to be 5 95 or maybe to f4 maryam's
aggressive queen position the a Bishop
b5 was played I think it's already
somewhat beyond repair they should be
five might not be the best move but it
is definitely how to improve on it yeah
now on deck player on place the rest of
the game very nicely started with Knight
to e5 simply ignoring that this rook is
hanging that's a very strong white
cannot take as yeah yeah this here is a
fantastic for combinational wearing
let's wait basically wins or heavy
pieces really funny as the night we
check this ya can't first heavy piece
second and the third is unavoidable with
black completely winning so this was a
licensed 95 how should write react it is
again already beyond repair I'm
relatively best seems to be something
that group is free but next attack is
extremely strong after that as well and
you can play around a computer wants to
do this just them activate the Queen's
look at the importance on him in the
game King at one more plate and now
Queen to f4 it's a very strong move it
has two ideas one could be to get into
these free potentially up to a second
one is just to invade yeah liya yeh to
at the end Bishop TCA tour flighty I
just grabbed the look but that now needs
to a situation where made us pretty much
unavoidable 93 earthly mate and yeah the
only way to defend it without just
giving up the queen is root 2
threatening mate thus Ruby to ruby three
check check check mate check
alternatively check me none of the other
made yeah so a quick win here for the
black player how did that happen first
of all he played this very nicely many
very energetically which made it a quick
victory black also could have played in
a much lamer way and just grind
something where this was just good i go
to the attack the main issue here was
that right it seems wasn't aware of the
yeah general strategy here that a
default push is part of it you played we
should be five and now lost love to move
lost time and black quickly grabbed the
center and the black queen here is an
active piece as an asset because it
cannot be attacked by Knight to c3 as a
bonus still this position here wasn't
all that terrible for wise if you play
that correctly with d3 instead of age 31
especially here these fries would have
given wide is still decent position and
in fact this as we had seen is pretty
much nothing you could argue that is
anybody here and widest banner he is
behind the development but he has a good
Bishop parent well
also not particularly grades are looking
at this on the whole time so wyd had one
or two opportunities to consume to come
back but once he didn't take them and
black got this full centralization going
on the whole situation they can't became
pretty hopeless for white yeah you
should really play like in the opening
here play with d4 don't be afraid of an
isolated pawn this is not such a big
deal developing quickly and more
actively with a center in mind is the
way to go yeah thanks for watching this
video bye-bye